votre forfait cellulaire le trouvez-vous
trop cher selon une étude récente le
prix des données cellulaires au Canada
est parmi les plus élevés au monde et ce
serait dû au manque de concurrence parce
que trois géants et leur filiales se
partagent presque tout le marché et non
pas intérêt à se lancer dans une guerre
de prix on entend souvent dire que dans
un grand pays il faut plus de poteaux et
d'antenne ce qui coûte cher mais en
Australie qui est aussi un grand pays
les données mobiles coûtent bien moins
cher parce que l'Australie a ouvert ses
portes à la concurrence étrangère au
Québec l'arrivée d'un quatrième joueur a
fait graduellement diminuer les prix de
20% par rapport aux autres provinces
explique Pierre Larouche spécialiste en
droit de la concurrence alors pourquoi
le Canada ne fait pas comme l'Australie
selon le professeur Larouche cela
s'explique entre autres par le fait que
nous fournisseurs sont perçus comme
partie intégrante de la culture
canadienne parce qu'il produisent aussi
du contenu nos gouvernements craignent
que la concurrence étrangère
affaiblissent ses grandes entreprises et
préfèrent encourager la concurrence
entre fournisseurs canadiens
c'est un choix mais cela a un prix qui
se reflète sur nos mensualités